Now that I've done with seven weeks of radiation and four rounds of light chemo or my squamous cell counselor cancer.
One of the best things I can do to help clean up my system and stimulate normal saliva production.
Well, the radiation really does a job on your parod and gland and that is hard for saliva production.
Our sub parodied glandular products out there one by biotics research.
You'd like to call it because biotics is one of the companies that contacted us so they don't allow any internet sales anymore.
So they don't allow their products to be viewed by anybody online so you have to call in.
We can still sell them but we can't show them on our store any longer.
Hello on the side of work.
So the just just know that you could call it it with a parodied product might be good for you.
It might be good to do a cheek swab again too.
Lots of mucus now they expect to dry mouth and still they need to be a feeding to just on speech there.
Okay good idea to do it maybe a cheek swab.